♫ “Money, money, money” ♫
♫ “Must be funny” ♫
♫ “In the rich man’s world” ♫
There was a leak yesterday
but I think I fixed it
because it isn’t coming out today.
Yes, it’s okay.
Medium, like that.
Stir it in there.
It’s still a little bit thin and…
...like cottage cheese.
Here she comes!
So how should I pour it?
Here in the corner is a good place.
I can hold the bucket with you.
Oh…
Get closer.
(laughter)
It’s not so nice.
Rauschenberg comes from Port Arthur, which
is an oil refinery town on the Gulf Coast
and the mud that you see here is bentonite
which is used in drilling
and I imagine he was familiar with the mud
pits that were the off-product of drilling
operations in Texas.
I mean, it is wild because when it’s finely
done it’s bubbling and blurping…
Here it goes!
So it looks totally primordial
but on the other hand it’s futuristic.
This is the technical cabinet
and this is where it all starts with the tape
recorder.
On the tape you have low frequency and high
frequency sounds.
And that will be divided—split up—in
the light organ, so that’s why some bubbles
bubble when it’s low frequency and other
bubbles bubble when it’s high frequency.
It’s the same way when the spotlights…
…in the disco work.
Is that why you test it with ABBA?
(laughter)
Yeah.
♫ “Money, money, money, boom, boom, boom,
boom, boom…” ♫
Now we need…
..eighty more.
Eighty more!
Give us like five more maybe?
Five?
Five hundred.
(laughter)